quand on pense à ce qui vous est arrivé
et comment vous êtes parti ça doit être
dur de revenir non ce qui est dur c'est
que ma soeur a disparu il est possible
qu'il se soit enfuie pourrait bien coin
c'est la bonne question
chaque jean à ce dur d'être regardée
bonjour tandina qu'est ce qui se passe
là thorpe la maman est morte
non chérie temps
connectez d'une manière différente des
autres tu vois ce que je veux dire cette
fumée
lenny j'ai peut-être une idée je vais
devoir jouer les deux rôles tant que je
ne t'aurais pas retrouvé
je suis là mon bébé je suis là tout va
bien
notre mère était la seule personne qui
pouvait nous distinguer vous créer des
problèmes
je ne veux pas être impliqués dans toute
cette histoire
lorsqu'avec lille vous discuté du passé
de quoi parlez vous
le passé c'est le passé
et tout ça doit impérativement rester
secret
je suis certaine que mon idôle l'une de
vous comme une trahison tu pourrais
ouvrir les yeux
disparu est un titre mais nos vies sans
même penser de conséquence vous leurrer
tout le monde régulièrement dans votre
propre intérêt
alors je serai là peu importe le temps
que cela prendra
quand vous dites
vous
de qui s'agit-il exactement
je ne suis plus certaine de le savoir
moi même
je suis contente de vous voir
de vous voir de vous voir
des pouvoirs
ceux-ci content de vous voir
[Musique]